congratulations to the tampa bay
buccaneers who won
super bowl 55 the ladies who slayed
those pre-game performances
and the weeknd who lit up the super bowl
halftime stage
and welcome to et live super bowl after
show i'm denny director and i'm cassie
delora and after
six months of emailing and zoom calls
and fronting
seven million dollars of his own money
the weekend finally
brought his 13-minute performance to
life
with his biggest hits take a listen
[Music]
my eyes it was so lit uh joining us now
to help break down the weekend super
bowl performance
is our very own alicia johnson what's
going on now
hey i'm excited to be here i feel like
i'm actually doing something and going
out
you've been in the house for too long
that's exactly right and that's why the
weekend you could tell he acted up
because he had the whole field
to himself let's get into it ladies
malicia's starting with you
what do you think is the moment from the
weekend's halftime show that everyone is
gonna be talking about tomorrow
um i mean i think there were a few
moments for me
i did one a bit more from his
performance but
he did promise that he was going to
deliver a cinematic
experience and that he did i don't know
if i was the only one but at the
beginning of his performance
i thought they were dolls in the stands
it took me a minute to figure out that
oh no those are actual people
but it was good to hear him blow through
a bunch of his hits he
you know saying house of balloons
starboy the heels
can't feel my face i feel it coming the
list goes on
and it really reminded me of how much i
missed concerts
so although you know i wanted more i
feel like this experience was just
bigger
than the weekend himself when i went on
twitter i saw his
day one fans people that have been
following him since he was an
underground artist just very proud that
they can see this man who they've loved
for so long
make it to the world's biggest stage and
then he has his you know tight-knit
group of people behind him he has three
people who are on his team
three men who have literally helped him
go from being homeless
to hitting the super bowl stage so it's
not just a win for
the weekend it's a win for a lot of
people here i love that
you know it's funny his team ahead of
the super bowl they talked about how
this was not just a bucket list item for
the weekend as an artist but for their
entire team like
you said they've been together since the
beginning and it's funny that you
mentioned the stage because
that i feel like is one of my biggest
takeaways from his entire performance
because it it kind of blew me away
because it really was
as melisa as you kind of said it was a
concert and what i mean by that
is it was a different setup than what
we've seen before and really
the pandemic allowed that in the sense
of
not having a stadium filled to capacity
and it's funny because
ahead of the super bowl e.t spoke with
the executive producer of the show his
name is jesse collins and he teased that
the weeknd was going to use the stadium
to present the show in a way
that it's never been presented before
and it's like bud light seltzer says
when life hands you lemons make lemonade
and i feel like that is what the weekend
did he really utilize
the entire stage to have those backup
performers
and make it really a spectacle and then
also being able to as you see right
there
freely use half of the field for pretty
much like the last portion of his set
but what i loved
the most my favorite part was it kind of
it kind of looked backstage almost
um but it was it was it's like a house
of mirrors it was this gold
set up where he had the camera um you
know kind of it looked almost like my
mother trying to facetime
he was like all over the place like that
turning on the zoom camera
he had he i'm not gonna lie he had us
all kind of a little dizzy with that but
i thought it was really cool the way he
just thought out of the box no pun
intended even though he was in a box and
look this is
i mean it's arguably the biggest
performance of the year and a big
opportunity for artists it's a tough gig
though because you do have to appeal to
the masses and that's why i think he
his setlist was right like i feel like
he picked all the hits that a lot of
people are familiar with while also
you know paying homage to his current
after hours era his current album
uh and i know that a lot of people when
it comes to the super bowl halftime
show their first question for the artist
who's headlining is like who are you
bringing out
well we didn't get any special guests
but that's okay because what we did get
was the weeknd
and an army of doppelgangers
[Applause]
[Music]
a bunch of abel's there in tampa and
also here
in los angeles we got a doppelganger
here give me a mask and i would have fit
right in jesse collins i could have been
your backup there too
i mean so obviously he had a whole army
of people who look like him with his
bandages again a homage to
his current album cycle after hours we
have seen
many performances and music videos of
the weekend
all wrapped up in bandages and in a
recent interview with variety he said
that the bandages
signify the absurd culture of hollywood
celebrities and people manipulating
themselves by superficial reasons but
i gotta say it's also perfect because we
are still in the middle of pandemic
and everyone was messed up you know
what's so funny is before the super bowl
we
again we spoke to the executive producer
of the show jesse collins we were trying
to get him to
tease what to expect and he mentioned
that the timing of the weekend's
performance during the pandemic actually
aligned with the story that they were
trying to tell
and now it all makes sense they were all
wearing the bandages which also
are the masks in the pandemic and it
seemed the stars aligned right there it
all made sense felicia can i ask you did
you feel like it needed
maybe another special guest like even
though it was so amazing to see the
sheer number of
men and maybe women too in the red suits
on the field did you feel like was
missing just a little specialness
you know maybe but i can't even think
about who
right who i mean maybe someone that he
was featured along with
i honestly think that he did the best he
could with what he had
as you mentioned it is in the middle of
a pandemic and i'm just
also proud of jay-z you know this is the
second super bowl performance that he's
curated under roc nation
and even though like i said this one
might have been a little underwhelming
the quality is there and he's delivering
what the people want
these are artists that the people want
to see you know shakira jayla we had
them last year
this year we have the weekend so he's
doing a great job on that end and of
course the weekend made history being
the first black
artist to anchor a halftime show since
the company entered that partnership
with jc um in 2019 so
it's a big deal i will say melisa when
you say you know
that the artist that people want to see
me as the people for a second i wanted
to see ariana grande
and the reason why i saw that is i
thought that maybe the weekend would
kind of
you know we are in the middle of a
pandemic it has not gone away
we understand that his show has been
altered because of this
so i thought he would take advantage of
having the technology
of you know having all of the monitors
that may be
you know kind of like ariana grande
would zoom in girl you were all right i
was gonna say you want ariana grande to
zoom in i would need her there
okay it was it would be such a huge okay
i digress
i disagree i was hoping for me
i undo that statement no because it is
you know a gig of a lifetime even for
those special
guests i was hoping for maybe a daft
punk surprise obviously he performed
starboy and i feel it come in which were
those collabs
with those artists and that would be
cool to see some edm maybe represented
on the super bowl stage but you know
what he really did turn it out he
brought the energy
he brought the spectacle and he said he
was going to bring something epic and i
think and he brought the fashion i mean
i mean come on speaking of fashion
and amazing talent let's get into the
national anthem because
r b singer jasmine sullivan and country
superstar eric church
they were they joined forces for only
the second duet
in super bowl history take a listen
after amazing and incredible version of
the star-spangled banner
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i get the chills again you know what's
so crazy for two people who had never
met before the super bowl in fact eric
church had never even heard jasmine's
music before believe it or not
they sounded absolutely incredible
didn't it work mel yeah that's the
beauty of it though cassie
the fact that eric has never heard her
music before
there are a lot of people who haven't
unfortunately
there are and it was a moment of just
i feel like unity and also just
awareness when it comes to jasmine's
undeniable talent for a lot of jasmine's
fans
this wasn't this was an i told you so
moment
or now you can see moment because
they've always we've always known
how amazingly
album fearless in 2008 and it's so
exciting because recently she dropped
her
her latest ep hotels this was the first
project
the first project she's dropped in six
years so fans have been hungry for new
jasmine music
so to see her drop that album and then
see her take the stage at super bowl
something she's never expected she
didn't even expect this to happen this
soon in her career
and you know so it's oh go ahead go
ahead i was gonna say it's hard to
interrupt you there mel but and
jasmine's performing
30 years since whitney houston's
rendition of the star-spangled banner
that i feel like really united the
country
with just her singular voice so to see
the two of them up there is amazing but
jasmine actually channeled whitney for
today's festivities in the rehearsal
and in the final performance she wore a
tracksuit similar to the one whitney
wore
in 1991 uh and then fans noticed that
she's wearing this like
headdress that looks similar to the
bodyguard
it's a what a cool full circle moment
melisa i wanted to ask you
and denny too a lot of people on social
media right now
are saying that jasmine could have done
this national anthem herself and
rightfully so she absolutely could have
had that moment
and that necessarily eric church wasn't
needed that's what i saw a lot of tweets
were tonight do you agree with that
it really was a beautiful collaboration
their voices mixed very well with each
other
but as i said the world was able to see
jasmine's talent she can one of the
greatest voices of our generation and
i've said that before
and of course she should she could have
held that moment on her own
but the bigger point of this moment was
the message of unity
so while she could have done it solo i'm
glad she did do it with eric
i'm glad that you brought up that
message right there of unity because
that to be honest
is the only reason why eric church even
signed on to do the national anthem
he has been very vocal in his career
that he will never do this type of
performance and it wasn't
until the riot at the capitol in early
january that was kind of the catalyst
for him to
change his mind he understood that there
we are in a time right now
of a lot of division and he wanted to
utilize this moment
to unite people and just the
the the significance of having two
artists stand there and sing a duet
is unifying in itself and then you have
a white artist
you have a black artist you have a
country artist you have an
r b artist so really i think you know
my hat's off to him for for
understanding the magnitude and the
symbolism of that moment
and so to so my response to all those on
social media who i
i do like i said i think she could have
handled that moment on her own 100
but i i understand the magnitude but i
also have to give credit to
jay-z and roc nation for this moment too
because this is the second
super bowl that roc nation has been
producing all the entertainment acts
and so it's clear when you see who they
chose to sing the national anthem
to who they perfor who they chose to
sing america the beautiful
who they chose to headline halftime it's
all about diversity i mean we're talking
about the same company and jay-z who
put on latinos uh at half-time for the
first time ever last year with jlo and
shakira so i think it was important to
just showcase
different genres different backgrounds
different ethnicities and different
voices and it really was
all about unity in fact et's michelle
turner spoke to jasmine ahead of the
super bowl and this is what she said
about singing the national anthem with
eric church and what she hopes it
represents
we definitely come from two totally
different uh yeah
everything um but i'm excited i think
it'll be cool
um to blend the different sounds of
music and and just show some unity
i just hope that it brings unity and it
shows that you can be from two different
um parts of life and come together you
know for a good common cause
basically what that performance felt
like
it felt like uh people coming together
for a good cause you know we deserve
that kind of like moment of unity and
also
levity too because it was just kind of
amazing i want the downloadable version
yeah can we get it on stream all right
download it oh by the way you guys don't
know if you caught this but deaf rapper
warren wawa
stole the show during the national
anthem a little bit too because i mean
he was uh you know he was performing
sign language
uh for the asl community during the
national anthem and everyone on social
media
was just loving him because look it he
was loving it too look at all this smile
on his face i love it you know
everyone else on social media was also
loving 23 year old r
b musician her who sang america the
beautiful ahead of tonight's kickoff
take a listen
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
she sounded great but how good does she
look too oh amazing
how what about the skills on the guitar
the guitar
she just she exudes this confidence
this aura to her that's just like she
can't be touched
what do you think this moment what do
you think this moment will do for her uh
literally her uh melissa well i think
honestly her is in a beautiful position
when it comes to her career she's been
doing this since she was
what 13 12 maybe younger than that and
now she's what grammy award-winning
artist she's really getting recognized
for her skill and her talent
one thing that i really admired about
her performance is the way she
did the way she sung america the
beautiful it was so
fitting for where we are as a country
right now it wasn't all about
you know the bells and whistles you
heard the pain
you but you also heard the love you know
you heard that
this is a country that is beautiful but
we got some work to do but i love it so
much and we are working
so i love the way she did her rendition
of the song earlier this week et's kevin
frazier got a chance to speak to
two-time grammy win or her about what
this opportunity meant to her
i'm a young black girl from the bay area
that never
imagined that i would be on a stage like
that and
um i i think it's a message to other
young
black women like you can do it too you
know there's nothing that you can't do
reach reach for for the stars you know
um and that's kind of what i think of
and being the first black woman to
do a collab with fender and to be able
to to play my guitar
on stages like this is is i think
inspiring and
it's it's representation man oh man that
performance i still have chills going up
and down my spine but the the superpower
of the women
the ladies tonight continues and i'm
talking about amanda gorman whose
breakout year just continues the 22 year
old poet became
a household name after her inauguration
day performance of her poem
the hill we climb and has since signed
to img
models and now she made history with her
pre-game performance as the
first poet at the super bowl take a
listen
let us walk with these warriors charge
on
with these champions and carry forth the
call of
our captains we celebrate them by acting
with courage and compassion by doing
what is right
and just for while we honor them today
it is they will every day honor
us okay she has some things to say
yep yes that last line is what got me we
honor them because
every day they honor us and of course
she was talking about first responders
and the heroes out there
something that amanda just really brings
power to
is the power of words i think she's
bringing
the significance of that to a new
generation how what we say really
matters and how we can tell stories with
not only our tonality but the way we
choose to say it just all of these
technical things she does
it's just always a joy watching her i
feel like i know her she's my life i
feel like
don't you we all feel like we know her
she's so relatable too but she's
speaking truth to power and i feel like
this really set the tone
for the game and the rest of the show
because it really was a show there was
so much entertainment you guys and by
the way
fun fact amanda tweeted before the game
that like while
she might some might think this
opportunity came from the inauguration
fame no she said she's been talking with
the super bowl for
weeks now um so she had to keep this
blessing a secret until now but talk
about
a major reflection truly truly her time
it's her time and it's no doubt about
that sometimes it's just your time and
it's her time
well it's a good thing it's also award
season too because i feel like she's get
her to the oscars
let's go let's get beta now i love that
well our thanks to alicia johnson for
popping in all the way over in atlanta
to talk super bowl